hume fox news senior political analyst
brit
this is what the democrats do the moment
we start to push
back and fight for ourselves they put
government roblox in place
you know they certainly seem to have
done that in this case uh i can't tell
you how much i admire what that young
man has done
and is doing i serve on the board of a
christian youth home out in
suburban washington virginia i've been
there for been there for years
founded by joe gibbs when he was coach
of the redskins back in the 80s
and it is doing wonders for really
troubled youth so the very kind that
that that your previous guest was
describing that he's trying to help
uh these are these are kids who the
regular school system
didn't work for and now to see
the school authorities who have done so
much damage over the past year
in the school shutdowns and so on trying
to block him from doing something that
obviously vitally needs to be done and
from all in from all the evidence
indicates works is really disheartening
um the school systems and educational
authorities are failing and yet what
they want to do most of all
is avoid competition avoid anything
would break their monopoly
it's tragic it fails kids it's an
outrage
brit you're someone that i respect
because you've been doing this for a
long time you've seen
washington at its worst at its best
you've seen
the power of government and how they try
to squeeze the american public
what do you think the overall goal of
the democratic party because they've
done a lot of
lip service we even did an autopsy on
these companies they promised
50 billion dollars during the marches
and all that but it's only been a 250
million dollars so
can they continue to get away with this
well it seems they can for now at least
it's worth keeping in mind here that a
big part of this
is is the education bureaucracy and the
teachers unions
um which are closely aligned with the
democratic party you can even make the
case that
they're one of the most important
elements within the democratic party so
when you see something like this happen
as you've seen happen within the within
school systems across the country
to the point where the teachers unions
were even too far left
for many many school boards so this is
you know the the the connection between
the democratic party and the teachers
union and
indeed the education industry itself is
pretty
is pretty much uh responsible for what
we're seeing
um i don't think parents over the long
term are going to put up with this i see
in this and in so many other areas these
days lawrence
the the building backlash um
we'll see it against the the waves of
crime that are happening we're seeing it
against the reaction against the
the schools and the unions um and
and against the lockdowns and the rest
of it um i think it's coming
i think it'll be felt in 2022 and and
perhaps spill over into 2024
but i think it's coming no doubt about
it brent i think they overplayed their
hands and now they're going to pay a
heavy price at the ballot box because
as you can see a young brother like king
is out there doing
the work and i think the people of
georgia are going to see it
and react thank you so much for joining
the program
thank you lawrence hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else